before we understand what polynomials
are let's look at the concept of terms
and expressions 14x Z plus 53 y -3 there
is a plus as well as a minus sign here
which means that we have three terms 14
exit 53 y + 3 the second expression is
23 x squared Y minus 4y cubed this
expression has just two terms 23 x
squared Y and 4 y cubed now we can move
on to understanding the most important
concept in algebraic expressions it's
the concept of polynomials as you can
see the word has been colored into two
parts poly means many and knowmia means
parts or terms in the case of algebraic
expressions and that's how the word
polynomial comes about there are
different types of polynomials a
polynomial can be an expression with
just one term or two terms or three
terms or maybe even a greater number of
terms all these categories come under
one roof which is the polynomial
expressions with just one term two terms
or three terms are given special names
an expression with one term is called
monomial an expression with two terms is
called a binomial and an expression that
has three terms is called a trinomial
mono is won by is two at tri is three
there is a common misconception that
only an expression with more than three
terms is called a polynomial that's
incorrect
all expressions which have one or more
terms are called polynomials let's look
at a few examples of each the number
seven is a monomial it's just one term
4x is also a monomial it's just one term
as for and X are multiplied even 3 a B
squared is a monomial and yes all these
expressions are also polynomials an
example of a binomial would be 4 plus X
the plus sign separates the terms
another example would be 3x y minus X an
example of a trinomial would be 3 plus a
plus B it has three terms one two and
three or maybe three CD plus a plus 8
again let me remind you all these
examples you have seen are polynomials
and an example of the last type would be
4z plus 9 plus 3 X plus y it has four
terms in all so remember a polynomial is
an expression which has one or more
terms
[Music]